-Hello, everybody.
Welcome back
to our temporary studio
in the captain's quarters.
You know, we've been going
through our viewer mail,
and while many of you think
the new maritime-themed set
is great,
some of you most certainly
do not-ical.
Oof.
I told you that joke stunk.
-Arr! Thanks for trying it.
-And since I did, can we maybe
keep the interruptions
to a minimum?
-Okay.
-Speaking of half-assed efforts,
the president is trying
to convince Americans
he suddenly cares
about the pandemic
he's been ignoring for months
as he also threatens
to send more secret police
to cities across the country.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
Donald Trump is
trailing Joe Biden
by as much as 15 points
in the latest polls.
He is as unpopular as any
president in modern history,
and he's facing a larger deficit
than any incumbent
has ever overcome
at this point in the campaign.
But as we all know, Donald Trump
is a master tactician
and a marketing genius.
It was only a matter of time
before he cooked up
a foolproof plan
to win back those voters.
And on Tuesday,
with the nation's eyes upon him
at a televised press briefing,
he finally deployed
his latest master stroke.
-President Trump was asked
late today
about Jeffrey Epstein's
alleged co-conspirator,
Ghislaine Maxwell.
She pleaded not guilty
to sex-trafficking charges
last week,
one of her alleged victims
describing her
as a predator and monster.
The president today saying
he hasn't followed her case,
that they've met numerous times,
and that he wishes her well.
-I just wish her well, frankly.
I've met her numerous times
over the years,
especially since I lived
in Palm Beach,
and I guess they lived
but I wish her well.
-Checkmate, Joe Biden!
Just like the Trump team
drew it up on the chalkboard.
In front of millions
of Americans,
the president publicly
sent well wishes
to an alleged sex trafficker
while reminding everyone he's
been friends with her for years.
I mean, you just can't teach
that kind of political talent.
Now all Trump has to do
is sit back
and watch the votes roll in.
Now, I know you Monday-morning
quarterbacks out there
might think that publicly
sending well wishes
to Jeffrey Epstein's wing-woman
100 days before
a presidential election is,
shall we say, a misstep.
But, you see, Trump is always
10 steps ahead.
When you go left, he goes right.
When you zig, he says
nice things about someone
who was recently apprehended
by federal agents
while hiding out
in a remote compound.
Because if there is one thing
that Trump's base
cares most about,
it's a woman whose first name
sounds like a French perfume
for someone who is
keeping a secret.
Ghislaine. Shh!
And again, one day we will
get a second close-up camera
for right over there.
My favorite thing about this
is imagining the staff reaction.
They only called
this press conference
to try to improve
Trump's poll numbers.
You know they must have tried
so hard to keep him on script.
"Mr. President, we just need you
to focus on the facts
of the coronavirus
and only the facts."
"Uh-huh."
"So just, you know,
stick to the script."
"Got it."
"All you have to do
is sound presidential,
and the media will eat it up."
"Don't worry.
I won't let you down.
Just one question --
should I remind people
that I partied with Epstein?
Is that a good idea
or a great idea?
I think it might be
a great idea."
And yet despite
this insane tangent,
the media still fell
for Trump's act,
simply because his team dosed
his Diet Coke with NyQuil
and got him to read
a prepared statement
pretending to take
the crisis seriously.
Before the briefing, ABC wrote,
"The president is displaying
a new tone
and a new level of engagement."
CNN called it
a "relatively sober tone."
And Bloomberg said,
"Trump reboots virus briefings
with warning
and a shift in tone."
Good Lord, I really think
you could duct-tape a spatula
to a golden retriever's paw,
and half of the media would say,
"Oh, my God, that dog's a chef."
What's wrong with you guys?
How can you keep
falling for this?
It's been five years
of this B.S.,
and still, every time
President Werewolf over here
manages to novocaine his way
through a prepared statement
without passing out
at the podium, you act like
he's a totally different person
all of a sudden.
You know,
I say President Werewolf,
but really, he's more like
a reverse werewolf.
He terrorizes townspeople
all the time,
and then he's normal
for a couple of hours
when there's a full moon.
"I owe you all an apology
for the past 30 days.
My behavior has been monstrous."
Look, 74-year-olds don't change
unless they're characters
in a Clint Eastwood movie
where a bunch of retired
bank robbers go to outer space,
even though all they ever
really learn is how to have
a slightly better relationship
with their estranged daughter,
let's say Laura Linney.
"You were never there for me."
"Those bank robberies paid
for your fancy college."
"I didn't want a fancy college.
I wanted a father."
"I need to go now, Becky.
We're robbing Mars."
Look, you know Trump's just
going to steal his phone back
and tweet some racist nonsense,
right?
He repeatedly used a racist term
for the coronavirus
in the briefing.
You don't even need to wait
until he tweets.
He morphed back into the real
Trump mid-press conference.
Just compare his supposed tone
change from his scripted remarks
to an off-the-cuff comment
he made just minutes later.
-It will probably,
unfortunately,
get worse before it gets better.
The virus will disappear.
It will disappear.
-My God, I'd say he suffers from
extreme short-term memory loss.
But then again,
he aced that cognitive test.
So what do I know?
It's too bad
coronavirus can't be cured
by correctly identifying
an elephant on a piece of paper.
Then Trump would have knocked
that [bleep] out of the park.
Of course,
the idea that the virus
will just magically disappear
is deranged.
And since the very beginning
of his political career,
we've known that both Trump
and the political movement
he leads
are deeply, deeply detached
from reality.
Sometimes that manifests itself
in small but bizarre ways,
like when he drew with a Sharpie
on a hurricane map
or claimed God
stopped it from raining
at his inauguration,
even though people in the crowd
were literally
holding umbrellas.
This guy lies about the weather
more than your local
meteorologist.
You told me we were gonna
have clear skies all weekend,
and then I end up
wearing a poncho to the beach.
Ugh. The last time I listen
to Thunder Rains.
And it's important to say,
this isn't unique to Trump.
The modern conservative movement
is a paranoid movement
obsessed
with conspiracy theories.
Remember, this is the same
political movement
that thinks the world's
scientists all got together
and fabricated
the climate crisis
as part of an elaborate plot to
outlaw airplanes and barbecues.
Good thing we elected
Donald Trump
to protect our flights
and social gatherings.
And now those same lunatics
think graffiti
and light property damage
constitute domestic terrorism.
For example, take acting
Secretary of Homeland Security
Chad Wolf.
You know, Drakkar Noir,
if it grew up to be a real boy.
Pretty sure this dude
had a minor role on "Entourage"
as a personal trainer
who's friends with turtle.
He looks like a guy
who on a first date
would tell you he was a commando
in a top secret army unit
called the Omega Squad.
And then you'd get home
and Google it
and find out Omega Squad
is a paintball range
two towns over.
Wolf put out a statement on
the administration's decision
to send secret police
to Portland
to snatch protesters
off the street
and stuff them in unmarked vans,
in which DHS uses the phrases
"violent mob,"
"violent criminals,"
or "violent anarchists"
a total of 76 times.
Is this a press statement or
a page from Rorschach's journal?
13-year-old, he's pretty psyched
about that joke.
It's bad enough
to sound like a fascist,
but at least crack open
a thesaurus.
The only time it's permissible
to use the phrase
"violent anarchy" that often
is when you're reviewing
the music of Stomp.
Guys, do we need
that many trash cans?"
Maybe one of you
could learn guitar?
Any time a government is calling
its own citizens
violent anarchists
should raise alarms.
So what did these supposedly
violent anarchists do
to deserve that name?
Well, you'll be shocked
to find out.
It's complete bull[bleep]
-Chad Wolf, he is the acting
Secretary of Homeland Security.
To justify
what Donald Trump is doing.
He tweeted out images of himself
viewing graffiti
that had been put
on buildings in Portland.
The DHS put out a statement
pointing to the buildings
it said had been graffitied
by "violent anarchists."
So the mission of the
Department of Homeland Security
is to deploy secret police
to the streets
of an American city
to stop graffiti and some
light property damage.
-Graffiti.
You're going full dictator
over some graffiti.
What's next, you gonna
send in SEAL Team Six
to arrest lovestruck teens
carving their initials
in a tree?
"Okay, he just finished carving
the heart shape into the tree.
Now he's going for the TLA."
"Take the shot.
Take the shot, Todd!"
That's right,
our government used graffiti
to justify sending secret police
to an American city
to abduct protesters
into unmarked vans
without telling them
who they are,
where they're going,
or why they've been arrested.
But it would be bad enough
if what they were doing
was using secret police to
enforce laws against graffiti.
That's already chilling.
What they're actually doing
is even worse.
They're just snatching peaceful
protesters off the street.
They're kidnapping people
and not even telling them
what they're being charged with.
-Federal law enforcement
officers
have been using
unmarked vehicles
to drive around
downtown Portland
and detain protesters
since at least Tuesday.
Personal accounts and multiple
videos posted online
show the officers
driving up to people,
detaining individuals
with no explanation
about why they're being
arrested, and driving off.
-One came from a 29-year-old
named Mark Pettibone,
who said that when
he was abducted,
he did not know
if the men were even police.
He thought they might be
far-right extremists.
"I was terrified,"
he told "The Washington Post."
"It seemed like
it was out of a horror/sci-fi,
like a Philip K. Dick novel.
It was like being preyed upon."
-Leave it to Portland to use
a literary reference.
If this happened anywhere else,
people would say it seemed
like something out of a movie
or at best a YA novel.
But in Portland, you get, "It's
like a Philip K. Dick novel,
less in sitting
but more in tenor,
the later works, of course."
And in case you're not a
Philip K. Dick fan, that's bad.
The dude wrote
dystopian science fiction.
None of it was ever good.
He never wrote a novel called
"Robots Took Over
and Gave Us Candy."
When a secret paramilitary force
is abducting peaceful protesters
in the dark of night
without identifying themselves,
that means even they know
what they're doing
is a flagrant abuse of power.
And you can tell
it's a flagrant abuse of power
because they're using shady
and irregular tactics to do it.
For example, federal officers
appear to be using rental cars
from Enterprise
to snatch protesters.
Well, at least we know they were
not kidding with their slogan.
Did you guys get a deal
on KAYAK?
I hope you got
the liability insurance
'cause I'm pretty sure
you're going to have
a lawsuit on your hands.
Man, what a [bleep]
advertisement
for Enterprise, by the way.
This reminds me of the time
in the '80s
when the KGB
did an ad for Hertz.
And now Trump is threatening
to send his secret police
to other cities,
and the rotten husks in the GOP
and on Fox News
are cheering them on.
President can't be bothered
to develop a national strategy
for a pandemic that's killed
140,000 Americans.
But to defend some statues,
he'll send secret police
to American cities
to abduct protesters.
He and his right-wing allies
couldn't care less about you.
They just want power.
If we leave these people
in charge
of our democracy any longer...
-It will disappear.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
So many New Yorkers
are turning to City Harvest
for help feeding their families,
and they need your support
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
Wear a mask. We love you.